[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the kaiju monster of smart internet
shows wait does that even make sense or
the oversized internet show about I
don't know I guess it sounded good in my
head but now just seeing it out I just
sounds stupid and also now that I think
of it redundant since kaiju implies the
monster half so I don't know now I'm all
screwed up anyway when it comes to
oversized kaiju monsters double
redundancy there no one beats give it up
[Music]
[Applause]
care who you are you can't beat a
rocket-powered flying turtle monster but
the most famous of the kaiju are the two
big ol classics themselves Godzilla and
King Kong over the years these two
enormous monsters have had dozens of
movies made about them I'm sure most of
you are already familiar with Godzilla's
backstory
he's a prehistoric sea monster awakened
by nuclear radiation but King Kong's
backstory well that's a bit more
mysterious or at least it was until
today because I did the research and by
looking closely at the new movie Kong
Skull Island past King Kong lore and
good old fashioned science we can start
to piece together the big Apes origin
and not only that but also some of the
hidden secrets that I predict you'll be
seeing revealed over the next few movies
in this guide you monster universe
that's been kicked off by Godzilla and
Skull Island
ready to go cue that ominous stinger
previously the only thing we knew for
certain about Kong was his home Skull
Island in the original 1930s classic
this island was geographically located
12 degrees south and 78 degrees east on
the map the closest real-life island to
these coordinates is the cocos island
otherwise known as the Keeling Island
and if you compare the Keeling Island to
Skull Island they're pretty much an
exact match a coral atoll teeming with
overgrown vegetables and a tropical
monsoon climate I mean the only real
difference between the two is that one's
renowned for its beautiful beaches and
the other has prehistoric dragon
creatures at a giant ape so pretty much
the exact same
and that was all we had for decades now
fast-forward to 2004 and the release of
Peter Jackson's King Kong remake an
Italian novel released alongside the
movie it's revealed that Kong and the
other giant prehistoric creatures on
Skull Island survived due to its
isolated location but is that even
possible look at some large monsters
from prehistoric times have survived
thousands of years past that ancient
extinction asteroid that killed off the
dinosaurs and be hiding out in some
remote island today well yes and you see
there are quite a few Jurassic age
species that survived the KT extinction
event or the Cretaceous tertiary
extinction event that's the fancy
scientific name for the events that
killed off the dinosaurs and when I say
quite a few I mean a bunch I mean we all
think of that asteroid hitting the earth
as an event that killed off everything
but in reality almost 84 percent of
marine life made it crocodiles certain
types of fish frogs even a few small
land mammals don't believe the lies your
third grade science teacher is peddling
but there is a key word here and that
word is small
after the asteroids impact with earth
the theory goes that the atmosphere
changed drastically
so some smaller species survived but
larger species boom completely wiped out
thus dinosaurs equals extinct but there
is one way dinosaurs actually could have
survived and that's underground in 2007
scientists discovered an underground den
of dinosaur bones suggesting that some
dinosaurs survived that initial KT
extinction by avoiding the extreme
changes in the environment in the only
place that was safe inside the earth and
we see that the new movie called Skull
Island actually backs that theory up
Houston Brooks one of the monarch
scientists on the hunt for the kaiju
name drops the Hollow Earth theory this
theory claims that was in the earth
there are hollow interior spaces that
have their own magnetic poles and
atmospheres per Brooks the dinosaurs
must have gone into these hollow spaces
surviving well past the KT event to the
1970s when the movie begins which
scientifically speaking in the
world is incredibly far-fetched but in
the converse is entirely possible and
looks to be true thus we have the
origins of the underground skull
crawlers and in a brilliant design
detail on the part of the movies
designers you can tell that the skull
crawlers adapted to a life spent
burrowed within the earth they have
sunken eyes and skeletal features it's
awesome to see that level of detail but
none of this explains calm he still is
hairy and muscular as ever showing no
signs of his species having to adapt to
living in caves for millions of years
there's something else going on here
so if Kong wasn't Netflix and chilling
since prehistoric times then where did
he come from to figure this out we need
to trace Kong's family history the
closest ancient ancestors to Kong are
the Gigantopithecus Blackie a species of
ape that existed from 9 million to
100,000 years ago these Apes originating
from South China and Vietnam were the
biggest Apes that ever walked the earth
standing at a whopping 10 feet tall but
obviously even at 10 feet tall called
dwarfs these giant Apes
according to Kong Skull Islands director
quote this is going to be the biggest
Kong there's ever been not ten foot or
thirty foot but a hundred foot eight end
quote
so that places in nearly ten times the
height of the Gigantopithecus and while
I admit that may seem initially like a
theory killer a recent study published
in the 2015 Journal of science tracked
the relationship between the sizes of
large animals and time according to
their study it took 542 million years
for marine animals to increase in size
by 150 fold comparing this statistical
growth to the Gigantopithecus Blackie's
9 million year history the average size
could theoretically increase by 150
divided by 542 million equals x over 9
million in cross multiply divide the
separate of the x and approximately 2.5
times uh yeah so at most it'd be like 20
feet and up a hundred foot mammoth
monkey that we end up seeing so yeah
that one ended up being a theory killer
but hey you know what that's ok because
there'd still be one fatal flaw in Kong
Skull Island the downed World War two
pilot Hank Marlow reveals that the local
tribes on the island had to survive
thousands of years against the skull
crawlers without any help from Kong then
out of nowhere the calls appeared and
fought back against the skull crawlers
protecting the tribe members but that's
a weird detail right giant Apes don't
just pop into existence they gotta come
from somewhere it's almost like Kong was
placed on the island
rather than grew up there and that's
exactly what happened if you pay close
attention to the new movie there's a
blink and you'll miss it cameo by a
familiar name that gives this whole
conspiracy away when Marlowe reveals the
islands history to the group of
survivors they're in a temple the
natives built to worship Kong and
where's that temple located inside of a
ship but why would the natives ever
build their temple in the decrepit
bowels of a ship instead of say a cave
or something well as the characters
enter into the ship temple for a few
seconds we see the ship's name the
wanderer now for those of you who are
unfamiliar the wanderer is the name of
the ship from the 1930s film the ship
that transported King Kong from Skull
Island to New York but in this new
reboot the wanderer is entrusting on the
docks of New York but instead it's
rusting away on Skull Island
this new reboot has deliberately
inverted the boats whereabouts
suggesting that Kong wasn't brought from
Skull Island to New York as it's always
been but instead was brought from New
York to Skull Island the locals have
created an altar for Kong in the ship
that delivered their Savior to them now
before he called me bananas remember
that the most important thing about this
new version of King Kong and the thing
that separates it out from all previous
versions is that it's a part of a shared
universe with Godzilla because everyone
wants to be Marvel these days and in the
2014 Godzilla movie we actually learned
the US government already knows about
the existence of kaiju as early as 1850
in fact the kaiju are such a threat that
the US government forms monarch a secret
organization to hunt and study these
giant monsters monarch even lures
Godzilla to an island where they
detonate a nuke to kill him of course
this nuke has the opposite effect
Godzilla actually gets stronger with
each dose of radiation so facing
monsters that take their greatest weapon
of the atom bomb and treat it like a
shot of power thirst what
could monarch possibly do other than
create their own monster and that's not
just me spitballing just look at the
company name itself in the real world
monarch is a real company a company that
according to their website collects
information on genes and mutations for
biomedical research and if you think
it's just a coincidence that the
fictional monarch government agency and
this a real scientific institution just
so happened to share the same name look
no further than their logos they're
almost exactly alike to sideways
infinity symbols what I'm saying is that
in the movies King Kong isn't just some
random prehistoric ape the science and
timelines just don't add up but you know
what does gene mutations done by monarch
I mean scientists are already using gene
mutation to increase the size of animals
researchers at the Salk Institute
created genetically stronger and larger
mice by suppressing specific genes and
genetically modified salmon are
programmed to grow year round instead of
just during spring and summer after just
18 months these salmon were almost
double the length and three times the
weight of a normal salmon so it's not
that far of a stretch to say that a
fictional government organization named
after a real organization that
specializes in gene science would use
this exact same tech to craft
genetically larger apes as we learn in
Skull Island / Marlow King Kong's only
just a kid which doesn't actually make
sense on paper given that the lifespan
of a typical ape is 40 years and Marlo's
been stuck on the island for 26 long
should be pushing middle-age and yet
King Kong is still only a kid why well
because of genetic modification during
puberty and animals there's an increased
production of the hormone estrogen the
high concentration of estrogen in the
blood causes growth plates in the bones
to fuse thus closing down growth centers
of bones and preventing my pimply
sixteen-year-old self from getting
taller however if you manipulated teen
paths genes to reduce the production of
estrogen during puberty than the size of
my nerdy Dockers wearing self would
increase without limit I would finally
become the tall masculine God that I had
always envisioned myself to be the same
applies to Kong
if monarch had all
turned the Apes genetic makeup to keep
him growing what they essentially did
was delay his puberty keeping him as
Marlo says only a kid so then what is
the true lineage of King Kong well let
me break it down for you in the 1850s
scientists discovered the existence of
kaiju life living within the Earth's
surface they try everything to defeat
these monsters bombs nukes radiation
poisoning but nothing worked
spaced with an unprecedented threat they
decide to fight fire with fire
creating their own genetically modified
creatures super large Apes after
creating these Apes they ship them off
to an isolated island an island per
their research that may be a hot spot
for kaiju life they wait for over 60
years for their Apes to grow and evolve
on that island but in the 1970s as their
money and influence dwindles monarch has
no choice but to prove to the government
that their research wasn't for naught
they send two scientists armed with a
couple of bombs and a camera on a trip
to Skull Island to document the fruits
of their labor once over the island
these scientists drop bombs awakening
the kaijus dwelling beneath the earth's
surface all to see if their monster King
Kong has what it takes to defeat them
the whole trip to Skull Island in the
new Kong movie is nothing more than a
test run to see if monarchs masterpiece
King Kong has what it takes to defeat
humanity's greatest threat Godzilla
it's just gonna take until 2020 in the
hole connected kaiju universe to see
these two skyscrapers sized monsters
finally cross paths but hey that's just
a theory Oh
film theory and cut remember a few weeks
ago when I did that episode on The
Walking Dead and talk about how the
series is all touchy-feely got to
interview Robert Kirkman the creator of
the series to talk to him about theories
both the good like secret Clues hidden
in Teresa's death and the bad like the
coma theories you heard it here oh well
he and his team enjoyed the interview
and the episode so much that they put me
as a character in their video game
Walking Dead road to survival how cool
is that
apparently I'm a savior and armed to the
max so if you've ever wanted to team up
with me or feed me to a horde of hungry
bees eager to tear out my throat with
their teeth then download walking-dead
blow to survival and when you find me
take a screenshot and sit it on in I
would love to see you guys mutilate my
twitching on dead corpse and hey a very
very special thank you to the walking
dead and their gaming team Scully for
partnering with me to make that happen
get slaughter and my friends I'll leave
a link in the description I am so
excited about this opportunity and I am
so excited to share it with you guys so
go out there find me and enjoy the game
it's free to download so really there's
no excuse outside of I don't have a
phone in which case that is a perfectly
valid excuse but otherwise find me and
kill me now if you'll excuse me I gotta
prep for next week and I believe the
seas are calling my name
[Music]